[Music]
good evening and welcome to a special
and unusual edition of Tucker Carlson
tonight a happy Edition it's the new
year
as the new year begins 2023 with
everything that's going on in the world
it is easy to feel well a sense of
impending doom you can spend five
minutes watching TV or browsing social
media and you would come up with a
million reasons why this country is done
so despair is more tempting than ever
but it's not the whole story and because
it's not we're taking the next hour to
show you the other side yes this country
has problems we wouldn't have a very
interesting TV show if it didn't but the
truth is this country also has an awful
lot going for it more than any other
country in the world great people deep
natural beauty and a culture-wide love
of animals which matters
so even where there is tremendous
suffering all of that shines through
that's the gift subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight